the Italiano way on Monday with the
banana family yes okay so first and
foremost let's talk about your family
you know what's the celebration like
with you guys well it's big take us at
home take us to the living room it's
loud nobody's yelling it's just loud
right but that's like all Italians I
feel like
um it's a lot of Meatballs it's a lot of
pasta
um You're Gonna Leave very full so make
sure you don't eat yeah lots of wine
make sure you don't eat for like three
days
um yeah it's
um it's a lot of fun nothing really like
a big Italian family I agree I agree so
you're inviting all of our Las Vegas
families and tours too to come celebrate
with you guys on Monday what's going on
at the Trattoria reggiano on Monday well
um we have some family recipes that we
um pretty much highlight every day on
our menu they just feel kind of extra
special on National Family Day naturally
um so like our meatballs for example
that's a recipe brought from our great
grandmother and so my dad who started
Trattoria the whole company he brought
that into our restaurant and it's like a
combination of pork veal and beef so you
can't really find anything like that
here I feel like so very special well I
kind of feel like I just I need to taste
it you can go ahead yeah so while I do
this DJ I want you to explain you know I
love that you guys say that your family
owned restaurant that values quality
time with family at the dinner table you
know what does family mean to you guys
in celebration of national family day
well you know at the end of the day
family are people that you're born with
you grow up with but you have to realize
that you don't have them forever so just
any single moment with them is family
time if you acknowledge it in the moment
and enjoy it it could be anything like
waking up having tea going to Trattoria
having a glass of wine
eating some meatballs which is delicious
by the way I'm going for the the
cheesecake no we're having some garlic
knots you gotta dip a garlic knot in
yeah
that was beautiful Gigi and now Maria
tell everybody how they can come hang
out with you guys on Monday is their
reservation necessary yes so you can
make a reservation on open table you can
call us
um you could even Facebook message us
I'll be the one answering that if you
decide to do that
um wow so let me tell you sorry I did
not hear I didn't hear anything music
wow please tell everybody let me show
you a little bit about that so it's not
like any normal cheesecake no it's not a
cheesecake and it's a sicilian recipe
and I say Sicilian specifically because
Sicilians are very proud of being
Sicilian Italians so it's ricotta cheese
compared to normal cream cheese which
makes it like light and fluffy there's
some lemon zest orange zest yes that's
what I'm tasting yes it's really light
but like you still want to eat a whole
cake of it oh my gosh you guys this is
amazing you've gotten to eat this your
whole life yes thank you banana families
and
all right
awesome